Một bụng thật tảm, ngà kêu gọi các bên cần hết sức thận trọng khi nhất đến bu khí mệt tử.
Nói ra phân một viện tiền gremlin, ông đi Metry Pescoc, cụng cho biết, ngà không xem tuyên bố công trọng về việc liệu động hai tổng em hạt jành đến các khu bực thiết hợp là giấu hiệu của lâu tháng các thằng.
Đông thời nhận mạnh các tổng em nghĩ bố luôn trọng trạng thải sẽ sạch chiến đấu.
Chứ đó, cho một bài đáng trên mạc sôi trước show, tổng thủ miếng luôn năng trọng tuyên bố,
điều động hai tổng em hạt jành giảm giữ phòng trường hợp, lời đe zua sử dụng của khí hạt jành của phỏ chút thì hồi đồng ở linh ngà đi Metry Pescoc,
linh quan tệ mạnh khổ chình gần đời giống trọng và mấy bởi vì đẹp.
Nếu phân ngôn điện quan đi nông Pescoc cũng từ cho biết lợp,
điều ông mới bởi đẹp còn nên tiết chế hay không, đông thời nói rằng mọi cuu gia đều có những người cường dẫn.
Tuy nhiên ông Pescoc hàng định quan điểm và hạt động đối ngoại của ngà đuất quyết định bởi tổng thống đứa nghiệm bệnh của tiên
chưa không phạt các thành viên chính phủ khác. Ông cũng nhấn mạnh rằng bấn đề hạt nhân là vô cùng nhẹ càng và dễ gây lò lần cho công trúng.
Giờ đó các cá nhân cần tránh lắm trường trong thêm càng thẳng bằng lời lệ gái gác không cần thiết.